okay very exciting new thing that we are
participating in on YouTube our channel
has been selected among an elite group
actually I don't really know if the
group is elite but it is a group I guess
to beta-test the YouTube sponsorship
feature and if you've been on our
YouTube channel recently you might have
seen that there is a new button below
videos and also on the channel homepage
which says sponsor this is a new thing
not every channel has this but it's real
it's not a scam under most of our videos
next to the subscribe button you also
now see the sponsor button if you click
the sponsor button you will see that for
$4.99 a month you can become a sponsor
of the david pakman show YouTube channel
and you get a number of benefits which
are listed and you can check it check
them out when you click the sponsor
button including exclusive access to a
badge in comments and live chat which is
awesome
people will see a sponsor only icon next
to your username when you comment you
will also get sponsors only posts in the
new YouTube community tab sponsor
thank-you videos ex early access to long
form deep dive videos and a bunch of
other really great stuff and the
beautiful thing about this is that we
only need it only put a different way if
one percent of our YouTube subscribers
decide to sponsor our channel we solve
all D monetization and other financing
issues we have about four hundred and
forty thousand YouTube subscribers
currently we have had without promoting
sponsorship at all about 50 people have
signed up to become sponsors which is a
great start but I'm calling this the 1%
project because if just 1% of our
YouTube subscribers which would be 44
hundred subscribers click the sponsor
button and do their $4.99 a month we
almost can eliminate all commercials and
ads from the show I mean that's how
significant it would be and we would be
funded by the 1% rightly but the good 1%
right this isn't this is where would you
wanna be part of the 1% so consider
pressing that sponsor button this is a
new thing you might not be seeing it on
some of the other channels that you
follow again because it is in beta it
has only been released some channels and
in fact I would presume that if it goes
well and lots of people become sponsors
YouTube might roll it out more broadly
which would give you an opportunity to
support some of the other channels you
watch financially so that's another
reason to be an early adopter of the
sponsorship thing which is that if it
doesn't go that well if it doesn't have
a high adoption rate I would tend to
doubt although I have no inside
information I would tend to doubt that
YouTube would expand it to everybody so
very exciting hit that sponsor button
the target is 1% of our audience that's
all 1% of our audience can really
dramatically change the funding for the
program we've got 50 sponsors so far
let's get to 4,400 I'll check in with
you next week about our progress